Boys. Welcome back to the channel. As you guys know,
been investing millions of dollars into the studio, but I got a camera.
I don't know how to really operate. And I pressed the wrong button.
I just want to show you guys this. I screwed up the white balance. Okay.
Look at me there. Look out tan. I was,
and then now, somehow I mess. I'm going to figure it out my half Cuban side.
When I turn this setting on left the building. Okay. And the white,
the whiteness that I have in my running through my veins, hostile takeover.
But anyway, I'll be trying to get that somewhere in that look back and look,
it's not that I'm vain. I just don't want to be accused of identity theft. Look,
there's already one too many of these, a pale half Cuban boys with beards,
his name, Steven on the internet. You know what I mean?
Like that's not that's, that's not us. Our name is not Steven Bucknell.
So anyway, that's my point. So this is my official announcement. It's my camera.
It's the million dollar setup it's screwed up right now. I'm going to fix it.
But in the meantime,
I had a professor who just was arrested for secretly
working for China. And that's, I mean, that's it. That's,
that's the headline and it's absolutely true. Check this out.
This is so blow your mind. So somebody sent me this as you guys know,
I went to Texas a and M hold your applause, please.
Stop it. Stop it. Stop it. Stop it. Stop it.
Stop it. Stop it. Okay. Keep going, keep going.
I know it's kind of a big deal. Okay. I went to Texas a and M anyways,
I saw this little article in the battalion and it said
Texas a and M professor arrested,
accused of lying about Chinese affiliations while working with NASA.
And so I see this guy, I'm like, Oh,
it's just probably some guy that I don't know.
And then I'm like zooming in and I'm like, wait, that guy looks familiar.
And then I thought to me, I mean, it's been a while since I've been in college,
it's been a few years now, but I was like, did I take that professor?
I felt like I had that professor before I could swear I had them.
So I looked them up Zang dunk Chang, or, uh, Dr. Chang,
as we knew him and sure enough, like I'm bad with names,
but I remember this guy. I was like something about this guy.
I know I had it before. Check this out, dude, ladies and gentlemen,
I log back into my old account and look back in
2015. And yes, I took him. I had his safety course,
uh, safety engineering course. And I had Zang Chang in Monday,
Wednesday, Friday in the blocker room, which was a building on campus.
Now, what does that mean, guys?
Am I qualified to speak about whether Zang shanks worked for
China or not? I think so. In fact,
I think I have incriminating circumstantial evidence to add if the DOJ wants
to call me, you know, I'm ready to CAUTI nine, this guy,
because when you go look at the court order, he had been committing this, uh,
these actions from April, 2013 until present,
which means at the time I was taking his course,
he was fraudulent currently, uh,
working for China while also working for America and maybe
allegedly, maybe stealing trade secrets from American companies.
Now I want to talk about my experience with them because I kind of feel bad
because frankly, this guy was a great professor.
Well by great professor. I mean that, I got an a, in his course, dude,
I was not the perfect student, as you can tell,
but I got an a in that guy's course. And the one thing I remember about it
is that I never went to that class at the beginning of every year in college,
you try to determine which of these classes do I actually actually,
you have to attend and which ones can I just study right before the test?
This was definitely a study right before the test. And I thought at the time,
huh? That's weird. A lot of these professors were like,
you had to show up consistently, but now it makes sense.
Cause I think this guy was too busy working for China to really,
really run the class. And it's not just me saying that, like,
just look at the criminal complaint.
It says that during and about nine months he spent approximately
133 days outside of the United States.
So he is going back and forth between tryina and the us all the time.
So how are his students going to show up?
He doesn't even want him to show up because he's not going to be there,
but it's hard for me to hate on him too much because at the time,
and still now I was like, when you're trying to keep your GPA up, I mean,
it's pretty nice to get an a, for barely showing up at all.
So I don't know. I'm conflicted about this one.
I really am because I liked saying dunk Chang. I really did.
And now it turns out he may have been a Chinese spy. And I, uh,
I don't know really how to feel about it because on the one hand I want him to
get acquitted on the other end.
He definitely lied. He was very sneaky.
Apparently my professor was trying to become something called a TTP
recipient. It's called the Chinese talent program.
But allegedly it's just the way that they pay scientists who work in
America. Um, and they get them to steal IP.
I mean, that's definitely simplifying it, but
that's basically what this thing alleges.
It's kind of a big deal that this guy was working for NASA.
He got this almost million dollar grant with NASA,
which he was the principal investigator on.
And he was constantly certifying throughout that process that he has no
affiliations with China because he's going to get these us grant to work on U S
technology.
And he conveniently forgets to mention that he had a Chinese
technology company that a key fob, Oh, Andy conveniently forgets to that.
He filed two Chinese patents while he's working for NASA based on similar
research. I mean, you can't make this stuff up, dude. He's, double-dipping hard,
not a good luck for Texas a and M and definitely not a good look for my
professor here. I don't know. I mean, on the one hand,
how do you guys feel having a professor that gives you A's for basically doing
nothing? On the other hand,
your professor is working for the Chinese government while getting NASA
grants and potentially handing over IP.
And it's not just Zang dog Chang who's, uh, you know, who's tied to China.
It's a bunch of these guys look at this.
This is a former Cleveland clinic researcher charged with fraud for failing to
disclose China ties. It's the same thing.
Look at this guy claimed Harvard scientists is arrested,
accused of lying about ties to China. It's an epidemic. I found this, uh,
paper in science mag four years after the national institutes of health began to
investigate grantees who had believed it failed to disclose their ties to
foreign governments. Officials still don't know the extent of the problem.
We learned of 150 cases in the last 12 months.
So this is a extremely bad,
and this was a very sneaky thing for St. John Jane to do.
And I'm disappointed in him as a former student of his,
but what I'm most interested in is to see what China's response to this is
whether they're going to try to get them back to the country or what I mean,
I don't know. We'll see. Anyway, that's it.
Let me know what you think in the comments below. Thanks for watching.
And don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].